[Music]
a surprise sister who's the key to the
apocalypse and a doctor with an
annoyingly lustful appetite even the
most popular shows can misfire when
introducing new characters Gilmore Girls
fans will never forgive April nardini
for dismantling Luke and lorelei's
relationship the grumpy Diner owner and
the newly minted Inn owner finally get
together in season 4 after years of
pining and filler relationships cue the
entrance of Luke's daughter April in
season six she stumbles into Luke's
diner with clunky Exposition about a
science fair and later concludes that
Luke is her biological father Luke
understandably wants to get to know his
kid but he's entirely out of character
when he hypocritically keeps her a
secret from Lorelei for months after
hounding her about honesty surrounding
her situation with Christopher meanwhile
April's mom Anna is even worse refusing
to allow Lorelei into April's life until
she's married to Luke despite their
engagement then just a year later she
fights to have Luke's custody taken away
for no reason crushing April in the
process after Luke and Lorelai break up
for a year when Lorelei gives Luke a
marriage ultimatum and sleeps with
Christopher and the Netflix Revival
picks up pretty much where the show
leaves off despite taking place a decade
later before showrunner Amy
sherman-palladino returns and properly
orchestrates their long overdue
emotional Journey morally and Luke
basically waste a decade of their lives
in Buffy the Vampire Slayer the show
teased Buffy's surprise sister Dawn and
Buffy's sacrifice for her sister long
before her arrival especially in the
form of bizarre prophetic dreams miles
to go
Little Miss Muffet counting down from
7-3-0
great riddles at the time it sounds like
rambling nonsense then Buffy dies 730
days later to save her sister in the
season 5 finale for some reason faith is
the one to tease the youngest Summer's
kid telling Buffy in another season 4
fever dream little sis is coming as it
turns out Dawn is a human embodiment of
the key that the villain Glory needs to
open the gates to every Dimension and
jump start the apocalypse Dawn's arrival
is made even worse when Glory feeds on
brains leaving her victims to void of
Sanity for some reason only those
individuals can see Don's true Essence
as the key so now in addition to
everything she's also the origin of a
problematic storyline just three seasons
later after Buffy sacrifices herself for
her sister Dawn kicks Buffy out of their
house
the departure of Topher Grace and Ashton
Kutcher left a gaping Eric and Kelso
shaped hole in the final season of That
70s Show and Randy takes the brunt of
the blame when Josh Myers joins the cast
in season eight fans were quick to blame
his character for the show's
cancellation yet if we're being honest
the series should have made its bow in
season 7 with the departure of Eric and
Kelso it's no surprise that a show about
a group of six friends can't sustain
itself with two of the core group
missing yet instead of bringing in
someone entirely new the minds behind
That 70s Show scrapped the original plan
to recast Eric with Myers and created
the new character Randy a clumsy and
deeply ill-advised attempt to fuse Kelso
and Eric's personalities together even
going so far as to throw Donna and Randy
together to mimic her chemistry with
Eric this Choice really ticked off fans
and it was the final nail in the coffin
For That 70s Show Joss Whedon apparently
learned nothing from the real reaction
to Don summers in season three of Angel
the character Connor shows up Midway and
presents a problem for The Buffy
universe's rules for vampires somehow
Darla gets pregnant after sleeping with
Angel even though they're both vampires
and are both technically dead the
concept of magic can only suspend so
much disbelief when it comes to the
deceased having babies the storyline
gets even Messier when the show
establishes that Darla doesn't want to
give birth and forces her to have the
baby anyway Darla tries and fails to
abort the fetus multiple times which is
pretty gross coming from self-appointed
feminist icon Joss Whedon Darla
eventually Stakes herself to protect the
child she's forced to have reducing her
to nothing more than a womb and because
Angel hasn't been tortured enough
apparently Conor gets kidnapped and
taken to kortoth where he's raised to
hate his father and seek revenge and
emerges back in the real world as a
teenager a couple weeks ago he was
wearing diapers now he's a teenager tell
me we don't live in a soap opera after
awkwardly feuding with the annoying
prodigal son Angel fans finally thought
they were free of the kid when Angel has
Connor's memories wiped to give him a
normal Suburban life but it doesn't last
Conor's memories come back and so does
he
the Billy Jenkins addition to The
Charmed Ones mix is yet another case of
a struggling show trying to revitalize
itself rather than spending the show's
final season on the core group of
sisters fans know and love Billy comes
into play in a central Arc where she
enlists The Charmed one's help in
finding her sister to add insult to
injury Billy has the same power as Prue
an original and fan favorite sister who
dies early in the show plenty of fans
are also still outraged that original
series characters like Wyatt only show
up for two episodes of the final season
in an interview with TV line showrunner
Brad Kern attributed Wyatt's absence to
budget cuts and he also shot down the
rumor that Billy was brought in for a
potential spin-off that hasn't stopped
fans from blaming Billy for taking away
screen time and resources from their
favorite characters in reality it seems
like budgets wouldn't have allowed for
anything else to happen Kaley Cuoco was
a relatively new actor and the show had
to do something to fill in in the gaps
of the many missing characters in
hindsight maybe the show should have
ended with season 7. Marissa and Ryan
can create enough drama for themselves
in the OC without help from the local
stalker but that didn't stop the writers
from adding Oliver into the mix toward
the end of season one of the show which
had already amassed a dedicated fan base
Marissa meets Oliver in therapy where he
begins manipulating her showering her
with gifts and gaslighting her into
spending every waking moment with him
knowing that Marissa has a bit of a
savior complex Oliver uses it to his
Advantage until he finally makes a move
Marissa turns him down and he responds
by pulling out a gun despite the show
being relatively new at the time of
Oliver's appearance the hatred from fans
was so intense that the series later
addresses it in a meta moment in season
three
I wouldn't have done it any differently
except maybe Oliver
by season eight of House the show had
long since gone off the rails in an
attempt to keep things Fresh House
Incorporated a revolving door of doctors
to assist the titular character in his
various career-ending Shenanigans yet
through it all no character elicited as
much irritation from fans as Chi park
there are plenty of Awkward characters
on TV that fans can't help loving but
Park isn't one of them just go on Reddit
on any post where she's mentioned to
find a Litany of fans who skipped
episodes and almost failed on the show's
final season after she was added even
during her few likable moments she makes
everyone in the room uncomfortable
including the audience and that level of
cringe is impossible to tune out her
character becomes downright unbearable
when she continually sexually harasses
Chase thinking that every time he's nice
to her he wants to sleep with her Chase
has his own issues with pestering
Cameron toward the beginning of the
series which is bad enough but after six
seasons you'd expect the writers to grow
from this Trope yet on top of her
endless uncomfortable romantic overtures
fans have to endure creepy Daydreams
where she hooks up with the object of
her fantasy like many ill-advised
character editions Ashley Seaver is a
victim of circumstances on Criminal
Minds when Rachel Nichols joins the show
at Siever in season six she only stayed
for 13 episodes her character's Edition
came after fan favorite actors AJ Cook
and Paget rooster were cut from the show
over rumored budget cuts however rooster
cleared up that rumor in an interview
with the AV club saying oh yeah that
wasn't budget cuts CBS had just called
Ed bernero and said I want new women so
we were fired the fans were upset it's
unsurprising that after all of that fans
wouldn't exactly welcome their
replacement with open arms eventually
the show brought back both cook and
Brewster when it comes to describing
sieber the word useless seems to come up
a lot while describing her that being
said a lot of the fan outrage has more
to do with the internal circumstances
than the actual character who admittedly
has an intriguing backstory there's
nothing quite like a hated love interest
to get in the middle of a fan favorite
pairing in season 4 of friends Ross's
future wife Emily comes into the mix
after Ross and Rachel's breakup in true
Ross fashion he rushes too fast into a
long-distance relationship with the
British woman granted Ross and Rachel
are arguably one of the most toxic TV
couples of all time but that didn't stop
the ship from sailing into rough Seas
it's abundantly clear to everyone
including Emily that Ross isn't over
Rachel instead of breaking up with him
Emily gets incredibly controlling over
Ross's friendship with Rachel and things
eventually come to a head during their
hastily planned wedding ceremony hi Ross
I Ross Take the MLA take thee Rachel
someone they hardly even know instead
Emily goes through with it demanding
that Ross cut all ties with Rachel
unsurprisingly the Ross Emily
relationship isn't long for this world
Ross deserves more blame in this than
Emily but she really should have
demonstrated some self-respect and
kicked Ross to the curb before it got to
this point cousin Oliver joins The Brady
Bunch in its Fifth and final season and
many fans pin the cancellation blame on
him in reality the series would have
likely ended either way thanks to low
ratings if bringing Oliver into the mix
was intended to spike viewership the
plan did not pan out though Oliver was
only in the show for six episodes before
the Brady Bunch met its demise his
appearance led to the coining of the
phrase cousin Oliver syndrome which
describes the addition of a young
character in a TV show to shake things
up of course the clumsy attempt to add
in random children didn't stop there and
still shows up occasionally on Modern
shows by episode 6 of the original
Gossip Girl the series had already
amassed a passionate fan base it doesn't
hurt that the CW Show is one of the more
successful book to TV show adaptations
either however fans instant hatred of
Vanessa might actually have something to
do with her being equally insufferable
in the books the great thing about
Gossip Girl Is That fans are actually
supposed to hate all of the characters
at some point throughout the show par
for the course when it comes to a series
that opens a curtain to a bunch of
entitled spoiled teenage brats however
Vanessa paints herself as a martyr and
she's anything but Vanessa spends her
days on the show sticking her nose up at
the entitlement of those around her
while seeking the same privileges
playing manipulative mind games and
ruining people's lives all while patting
herself on the back for being a good
person at the end of the day most of the
Gossip Girl characters realize how awful
they can be Vanessa by contrast is the
biggest hypocrite and drama instigator
in the show and pretends to reject the
elitism and cruelty of high society all
the while
[Music]